- So it takes 2,700 people
to put on the Oscars and every
job is equally important.
Okay, the gaffers, the camera people,
the seat fillers, everybody, all right?
And oh, so what the seat fillers do,
I hear you, seat fillers.
I'll just explain what you do.
So when you get up to go to the bathroom
or if you're go going to
cry 'cause you didn't win.
Oh my God.
Actually, you know what?
Let me just show you
what the seat fillers do.
Okay. Here's a seat filler.
Can we get you up, honey?
You wanna go to the bathroom?
Okay.
- What?
- Let's just get you, thank you.
Seat fillers, love them.
Jesse, I loved you in "Power of the Dog."
- You know that, that was my wife.
- You're married to that seat filler?
Oh, that's weird.